-Hey, I'm outside Joe & Pat's
Pizzeria and Restaurant
in Staten Island.
I'm meeting up
with a good pal of mine to try
what some say is the best slice
in New York City.
Let's check it out.
♪♪
Ah.
That's what I'm talking about.
Good to see you, buddy.
-Yeah.
-Wow. Here we are.
-The real King of Staten Island.
-No, no, this --
-That's me.
-That's not true. This is --
I wanted you to be
in the New York show.
'Cause you're very New York
to me.
-I lived in Staten Island,
you know.
-You did?
-For nine days. South Beach --
-Did you really?
-I swear to God.
-Nine days.
-In the '80s.
South Beach, Staten Island.
He knows.
-Hi.
-How's it going?
-Jimmy.
-Casey.
-Colin.
-How you doing, Casey?
-Very nice to meet you, Colin
-Casey, how long
have you worked here?
-I'm actually an owner now, but
I've worked here my whole life.
-Yeah, why you insult him,
say he's working?
He said, "I'm an owner."
-What am I supposed to --
Assume he's the owner?
Have you ever
been here before, Colin?
-No.
-This is Joe & Pat's.
This is legendary.
-I know. Legendary.
I've heard of it.
-Joe and Pat
are actually my uncles.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-What's the go-to slice here?
-Never been here before, right?
-No.
-I would go with the original.
It's my go-to.
I actually had a few slices
for breakfast.
-I agree, too.
-All right. The original.
Oh, look at this.
-Whoa! Nice!
-This is what I'm talking about.
-Let me ask you something.
If I want salt on this,
you'd probably forgive me
because I'm Irish.
-You want salt?
-Probably when Irish people
come in here, they don't even
remark, no matter what we do,
'cause they're like, "Eh,
they're Irish. They don't know."
-Yeah. Irish people
don't really have a cuisine.
-Yeah.
-Everything's boiled.
-Want any spices or anything?
-They patronize us.
-No, thanks.
I would never insult you.
-The salt isn't working.
Oh, okay. I think it is.
This is good.
I like thin crust, too.
-Yeah, look at this.
-You know what I mean?
-Look at this.
Beautiful thing. Do you fold?
-Yeah, sure. What else
are you gonna do?
-Gotta fold.
-Yeah.
-Don't forget.
I'm from Brooklyn.
-Holy moly.
-You know, you think
you're better than their pizza.
-Holy moly.
That is unbelievable.
That is delicious.
-It's pretty amazing.
-Have you ever seen people
try to eat this pizza
with a fork and knife?
-Yes, I have.
-What do you do
when they do that?
Just sit there? Suffer silently?
-Yeah. Exactly.
-I always see, like, a mayor...
-Yeah. De Blasio. Of course.
-He came here once,
ate with a fork and a knife.
-Oh, my God!
-The number-one rule.
You gotta --
-You have to fold.
-You have to just
fold and eat, yeah.
-Oh.
-Wow! Wow!
-That's amazing.
-That's my reaction.
-It's really amazing.
-I got to see you
the other night.
It was a really fun dinner.
I had fun because --
You know, we lost a good friend
of ours, Norm Macdonald.
-Yeah.
-And it was good to get together
with friends
and just talk about him.
-Yeah.
-You brought up one of the best
jokes Norm Macdonald --
I forgot that he ever told.
Do you remember what it was?
-Yeah, one was where he goes,
"I walked in on my parents
having sex once.
It was the worst
30 minutes of my life."
[ Laughter ]
-That is one of the best jokes
I've ever heard.
That's a fantastic joke.
You have a brand-new show.
-Yes.
-It's called
"The Last Best Hope.
-Yep.
-What's "The Last Best Hope"?
You just have the answer
to everything?
-No, it's just because --
this country's obviously,
you know, in shambles,
emotionally and, you know,
the unification's gone.
So Abraham Lincoln said,
"We are," about America,
"the last best hope."
So I just change it.
I am the last best hope.
-And this is at the Lucille --
-Lortel.
Lucille Lortel.
-Theatre.
-Yeah.
-You're very French...
-[French accent] Well,
I don't know. Lucille Lortel.
[ Laughter ]
-You yell at me.
-Ah.
-To get tickets,
go to colinquinn.com.
Casey, do we have
that special pie?
-Yep. Got it ready for you.
-I got a special pie for us.
-Whoa!
-Look at this right here.
That's what I'm talking about.
-That's beautiful.
-Because -- You know
why I thought it was --
You know why I thought
it was perfect?
Because Norm used to bring you
out on "Weekend Update."
-Yes.
-And you brought me out
on "Weekend Update."
-Yes.
-I'll never forget it, bud.
I love you, man.
-I love you, buddy.
-Colin Quinn, everybody.
He's doing his show at
the Lucille Lortel Theatre.
And I want to thank Casey.
I want to thank Joe & Pat's
Pizzeria and Restaurant
here in Staten Island.
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show."
Look at that love right there.
-Beautiful.
-Come on.